plutôt très bien sûr l'ensemble puisque
déjà on a terminé les trois tests dans
de bonnes conditions les chevaux sont
encore en pleine forme il l'a encore
prouvé ce matin sur la maniabilité
les jeux équestres mondiaux en normandie
pour un normand tels que moi c'était
extrêmement important d'y être d'une
part et d'essayer de figurer au mieux la
france n'était évidemment pas favorite
au départ mais comparé aux derniers
championnats du monde que j'ai fait pour
l'instant j'ai un meilleur résultat que
ce que j'ai fait en 2008 qui est un tout
petit peu en deçà de ce que j'attendais
je voulais plutôt être dans les vins
l'objectif c'était celui-là
pour l'instant on est à la 28e place
pas si mal énormément de choses beaucoup
de progression de la maturité dans le
travail
et puis une envie de continuer sur tout
et surtout pas s'arrêter tout de suite